the harvard brain bank is one of the
largest rain banks in the country at the
moment we house approximately 5 000
brain specimens
my name is sabina bergeta i am the
scientific director of the harvard brain
tissue resource center which we
affectionately call harvard brain bank
our mission is to collect brain
specimens store them characterize them
and then redistribute them out to
investigators across the world
they do research on the human brain and
in particular on large number of
neurological and psychiatric brain
disorders such as schizophrenia bipolar
disorder parkinson huntington and many
others
the brain bank never sleeps we have two
sets of people that are on call 24 7.
we have a very limited time window from
when the person passes away to the time
we need to be done with this whole
processing
so this is going to be your first brain
late at night right now
we have to do it in less than 24 hours
our courier will bring it to mclean
hospital to the brain bank
so just put it out here so we're going
to take ourselves
there will be a dissectionist ready to
dissect the brain
that involves separating the two
hemispheres one of the two hemispheres
is put in a solution that preserves it
the other hemisphere will be dissected
in thick sections and those will be
frozen
we are not even close to understand a
lot of what we take for granted
our thoughts our instincts our feelings
our emotions
we have a lot of questions we still
don't know a lot of our brain functions
still will probably be studied for a
long time to come
a brain donation is in a very concrete
way a gift of knowledge and it cannot be
done
without the help of families and people
willing to donate a brain